c'est quelque chose que chaque parrain
devrait faire c'était permettre aux
enfants d'aller à la découverte
passe maintenant à notre invité du
samedi 20h
[Musique]
bonsoir
vous êtes né à Valence dans la Drôme le
22 février 1954 père gastro-entérologue
mère dentiste
durant toute votre enfance vous partez
chaque année en vacances dans le Var à
côté de Saint-Raphaël aux Issambres vous
passez votre temps dans l'eau à observer
la faune sous-marine à commencer par les
poulpes
doré avec une pupille très fine et quand
il vous fixe vous parlez tout à l'heure
d'empathie on a presque l'impression
qu'il a envie que vous veniez avec lui
ses poules pour les découvrirez encore
mieux à l'âge de 4 ans quand votre père
vous offre votre premier masque et c'est
quelque chose que chaque parrain devrait
faire c'était permettre aux enfants
d'aller à la découverte bien sûr alors
vers 10 ans que ce soit dans le jardin
de la maison familiale le jeudi ou bien
l'été aux Issambres vous jouez au
commandant cous avec deux nids votre
meilleur ami et là vous explorez en rêve
bien sûr les abysses sous-marine à
l'époque il faut savoir que Cousteau et
Falco le plus grand plongeur de tous les
temps sont des idoles nationales vous
voyez nous les suivons à la télé le
jeudi parce que c'était le jeudi soir
c'est vrai et c'était un moment
d'émerveillement alors à partir de 15
ans vous commencez à plonger avec des
bouteilles et vous découvrez la liberté
que procure la plongée vous découvrez un
monde absolument sublime en trois
dimensions en plus parce qu'on peut
avancer reculer monter ou descendre une
simple inspiration et vous vous élevez
comme un papillon et puis
une inspiration est beaucoup les
doucement sans mouvement vous pouvez
vous approcher des poissons comme ça
alors après quatre ans d'études
universitaires biologie géologique et un
doctorat d'océanographie
faites votre service militaire dans le
Sud algérien à Ouargla et vous postulez
pour un poste de directeur adjoint à
l'aquarium de Monaco là vous allez faire
la rencontre de votre vie puisque
l'homme qui dirige l'entretien n'est
autre que le commandant Cousteau quand
on est avec le commandant et qui vous
propose tout d'un coup de venir sur la
Calypso il vous dit c'est formidable
vous êtes trop jeune pour vous enfermer
dans un musée plutôt que Monaco venait
sur la Calypso c'est génial et donc on
est parti
du Commandant Cousteau c'est quand même
un sacré sacerdoce parce que les voyages
durent entre deux mois et un an quand
même c'est long c'est merveilleux c'est
merveilleux parce que l'équipe était
formidable je reviendrai souvent sur
cette idée d'équipe avec beber donc
albert Falco et tous les gens qui
étaient là il y avait une vraie
gourmandise commune et Cousteau nous
donnait véritablement les moyens
d'explorer qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
les moyens d'explorer c'est le moyen de
perdre son temps à aller à droite à
gauche on n'était pas là pour avoir
quelque chose de productivité mais alors
c'est terrible parce qu'il y a pas de
téléphone il y a pas d'internet vous
communiquez par morse avec votre fiancé
donc il faut faire des messages courts
très court un simple je t'aime c'était
guygeoise qui était
le tour du monde et ça revenait
deux semaines après
j'ai pu être ça alors la vie à bord est
assez simple et joyeuse vous jouez au
scrabble avec le commandant Cousteau qui
est assez mauvais joueur quand il y a un
mot qui n'arrive pas à trouver il va
chercher un vieux dictionnaire il voyait
bien qu'il n'y ait pas le truc dedans et
il était académicien je le rappelle donc
les parties avec beaucoup de valeur et
puis il y a un luxe incroyable parce que
il y a un hélicoptère à bord donc on
voyait quelque chose prenez les Vico
vous y allez quoi c'est des trucs qui
sont inimaginables aujourd'hui la
soucoupe c'était plus difficile à mettre
à l'eau trois tonnes et demi c'est un
peu compliqué mais l'hélicoptère non
alors en 1987 vous lancez l'idée folle
d'aller voir des crocodiles de mer les
crocodile de mer ça fait 7 mètres de
long alors vous vous rendez au nord de
l'Australie dans l'embouchure du fleuve
jardine et là vous envoyez un se mettre
à l'eau quand vous arrivez vous vous
jetez à la rivière et comme l'eau est
boueuse vous le perdez le crocodile a
disparu et à ce moment-là vous tombez
sur un python et donc je vois un python
me dit bah si on a pas le crocodile on
aura toujours un python à film er c'est
quand même toujours étonnant dont je
commence à nager et Michel fait les
plans de coupe et évidemment je me
recule et je et c'était le crocodile le
crocodile
nez avec le crocodile alors là le
reptile prend peur en fait il a envoie
valdinguer le Masque et la caméra du
cadreur et vous parvenez à nager avec
lui pendant une heure et même à le
caresser il Lacoste
[Applaudissements]
un crocodile c'est une peau
incroyablement douce et souple à
l'époque c'était la première fois et
tout le monde nous avait dit qu'on
allait être manger et on s'est dit mais
sur quel expérience vous appuyez vous
aucune puisque si on y va on sera mangé
et c'est ça qui est intéressant c'est
que cette plongée là bref elle a ouvert
une porte on s'est dit que il ne fallait
pas écouter ce qui était dit mais il
fallait s'appuyer sur une expérience
enfin les tester si le crocodile va nous
manger ou pas les crocodiles n'attaquent
pas dans l'eau ils attaquent à
l'extérieur quand je suis sous l'eau
d'abord je suis relativement imposant
avec mes palmes je fais presque 2 mètres
40 et puis je suis un étranger pour lui
lui il ne sait pas qui je suis moi je
suis allé à l'école et je sais qu'il est
plus fort que moi je sais qu'il est chez
lui mais lui il ne sait rien et je suis
pour lui un prédateur et jamais il ne me
considéra comme une
et puis il y a le danger alors il y a
des moments très très difficiles à cette
grotte à Bornéo donc aujourd'hui la
plongée est interdite tellement c'est
dangereux quoi rappeler la grotte aux
tortue parce que les tortues marines
rentraient dans cette grotte la nuit et
souvent si perdait tellement le dédale
est éteint important et ne retrouvant
pas la sortie de se noyer et nous avions
donc fait avec toute l'équipe
bertrancion didineur un film sur cette
grotte que d'autres ont voulu explorer
avec moins de moyens et comme il y a eu
des morts
elle a été fermée alors depuis une
douzaine d'années vous vous intéressez
plus particulièrement au requin blanc
alors le requin blanc c'est ceux des
Dents de la mer c'est les c'est les
mangeurs d'hommes vous décidez d'y aller
sans cage oui vous aviez pas du tout ce
qui allait se passer c'est la première
fois qu'on allait au contact de ces gros
requins blancs quoi absolument c'était
la première fois je m'appuyais déjà sur
cette expérience avec le crocodile et
encore une fois sur l'effet très simple
il n'y a jamais jamais eu d'incident
entre requin blanc et plongeur donc tout
d'un coup on remet les choses en place
il y a pas de danger particulier parce
que le requin blanc ne vous considère
pas du tout comme une proie mieux comme
concurrent et donc il peut essayer de
vous intimider mais d'ailleurs il y a un
truc incroyable c'est que pour faire
venir les requins blancs on met du jus
de poisson oui sinon il viendrait pas
voilà si c'était juste pour les
plongeurs il viendrait pas non non il y
a des milliers de plongeurs
alors quand il vous voit le requin blanc
donc ils fonce avant km à l'heure sur
vous les nageoires baissées les oui
gonflées et là alors là il faut pas
montrer qu'on a peur et ça
l'impressionne finalement et ça le
déroute mais tout à fait alors je dirais
à vendre revenir là-dessus d'abord
j'insiste sous l'eau on le fait ça en
équipe c'est toujours en équipe il y a
Pascal cobay il y a David recherche on
n'est pas seul et l'autre chose c'est
que si vous êtes
respectueux si vous êtes calme et bien
tout ça fait que le requin lui-même
lui aussi être plus calme et vous avez
conscience que votre histoire elle est
magnifique quand on écoute on se dit
c'est magnifique mais il y a des jeunes
qui vont vous écouter qui vont se dire
qu'ils peuvent aller nager avec moi
dans la baignoire mais vous savez
pourquoi qui n'ont pas le calme et
l'attitude que vous pouvez avoir
vis-à-vis de ses animaux vous avez tout
à fait raison deux choses la première si
c'était juste une plongée avec les
requins que nous a offert Jacques Perrin
au moment du film océan nous ne serions
pas ici ça n'aurait aucun intérêt un
guignol qui nage avec quelqu'un ça n'a
aucun intérêt il se trouve qu'il y a des
dizaines de plongeurs qui ont plongé
avec des centaines de requins différents
je parle bien de grand requins blancs et
on oppose une expérience de terrain à
des ondits qui s'appuient
essentiellement sur les fantasmes
extraordinaires qu'on dépeint Peter
benchler dans son roman et Spielberg le
film est formidable j'aime ce film mais
pourquoi prendre un film formidable pour
une vérité nous nous opposons voilà
une expérience de terrain et elle est
solide encore une fois sinon ça n'aurait
pas d'intérêt donc quand le requin fonce
sur vous vous nous montrez aucune peur
ce qui fait que le requin ça
l'impressionne et ça le déroute il
disparaît dans les abysses ou alors il
se détend et il se laisse approcher
alors par moment lorsqu'ils sont
vraiment sûr d'eux et souvent les plus
gros et quand je dis les plus gros c'est
ça mètre 50 c'est une tonne et demi et
c'est de gros requins véritablement et à
ce moment-là il y a des moments magiques
quoi vous êtes
épaule contre nageoire pendant quelques
quelques secondes minutes et les plus
longs moments c'est 12h30 vous êtes à
côté de ces animaux et quand on est à
côté de quelque chose qui vous dépasse
complètement qui est
tellement plus fort
ça vous remet d'abord votre place et
puis vous dites je communie avec quelque
chose qui relève de ce qui est essentiel
tout à l'heure on parlait de de
préserver des animaux je crois qu'on
relève tous on a tous des racines si
profondes dans ce monde vivant que
lorsque tout d'un coup on le touche
ça vous bouleverse pour toujours et tout
à l'heure vous disiez
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire mais emmener
vos enfants voir le monde Liban le vrai
pas le champ de maïs une nature sauvage
voilà pourquoi c'est indispensable à
nature sauvage parce que tout d'un coup
ça nous remet notre place alors pour le
tournage du film
océan de Jacques Perrin ou multiplierait
les expéditions à Guadalupe une île au
large du Mexique sur la côte Pacifique
où l'on trouve les plus beaux spécimens
vous en filmerez évidemment beaucoup
pour le film et c'est toujours pour ce
film que vous traquerez les baleines
bleues dans les baleines bleues c'est 30
mètres de long 120 tonnes
sa gueule fait 8 mètres de diamètre son
pénis de mètres 40
c'est vrai c'est vrai on a plus souvent
l'occasion d'avoir à faire à sa gueule
et je vous garantis que c'est quelque
chose d'extraordinaire c'est une
expérience qu'il faut qu'on partage
alors j'ai vu ma première baleine cette
année
en Guadeloupe la baleine bleue elle
mange 3,5 tonnes de krill de crevettes
plus par jour
alors voilà donc il vous faudra 28
semaines d'exploration sur trois ans
dans la baie de San Diego en Californie
pour les pour les trouver quoi c'est pas
c'est pas évident
nager avec elle c'est pas évident
d'abord parce qu'elle passe extrêmement
vite donc on repère les banques grilles
qui sont à la surface et qui sont par
descendus parce qu'il monte pendant la
nuit après il redescend pendant le jour
et les baleines elles viennent
évidemment gros berger en ouvrant donc
cette gueule extraordinaire et avec
David referte là encore une affaire
d'équipe
de tornade de petites crevettes comme ça
il fait nuit on est piqué partout on
sort tout d'un coup c'est tout bleu mais
c'est la baleine mais c'est tellement
géant on n'a pas d'idées de la taille
d'une baleine ne cherche pas à cette
échelle on ne vit pas à cet échelle
c'est très haut c'est très grand et ça
défile ça défile ça défile et puis un
moment donné cette nageoire caudale qui
est grande comme une aile d'avion
7 mètres et vous êtes dessus pour
quelques secondes à ce moment-là vous
dites je suis le roi du monde mais oui
c'est merveilleux on a envie d'offrir ça
à tout le monde on a envie que tout le
monde puisse faire ça
vous dites qu'il faut montrer les
animaux la vie sauvage c'est vrai mais
ce désir c'est loite une émotion immense
que de nager avec une baleine mais ce
désir qu'on les gens d'approcher ces
animaux ça dessert les animaux parce que
il y aurait pas de watching aujourd'hui
il y aurait plus de baleine je suis sûr
d'une chose vous pensez ah oui
grâce au profit qu'elle peut générer
elle aurait balayé tout ce qui reste de
baleines aujourd'hui il faut savoir que
grâce au moratoire la plupart des
populations de baleines sont en
croissance et hors de danger
d'extinction oui quasiment toutes la
baleine bleue on pense qu'il en reste
3000 dans le monde
ça dépend quelle population en gros
c'est 10000 parce que les baleines d'eau
il y a différentes populations on a
débile baleines c'est infiniment moins
que ce qu'il y en avait avant la chasse
industrielle mais ça prouve une chose
quand on laisse à la nature des espaces
de liberté elle revient et elle revient
en force les grands cétacés mais aussi
les pinypet c'est-à-dire les phoques les
otaries tout ça depuis qu'on les chasse
plus les populations exposées ça vaut la
peine de se battre parce qu'à tous les
coups on gagne bravo
très bien merci et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de innarditude abonnez-vous
et mettez un pouce bleu